en esta jornada de acción global por el
aborto legal y seguro mujeres de
distintos colectivos marchan por la
capital del país para exigir que se
respete su derecho el derecho a decidir
sobre sus cuerpos en septiembre de 2021
la suprema corte de justicia emitió un
fallo histórico al resolver la
legislación de Coahuila determinó que
ninguna mujer puede ser encarcelada por
la interrupción de su embarazo sin
embargo no todos los estados han
adecuado su legislación aquí Brenda está
el día de hoy Brenda qué le dices a las
autoridades Pues estamos aquí para exi
es que velen por nosotras las mujeres y
las personas que están antes que no solo
son mujeres que esto es un asunto de
salud de derecho a la salud a la
reproducción queremos educación sexual
integral en las escuelas queremos
derecho a decidir sobre nuestros cuerpos
que saquen la religión que saquen sus
intereses políticos y que vean por la
seguridad y la salud de todas estas
mujeres que están atrás y adelante bueno
Muchas gracias Brenda son solamente 10
estados de 32 entidades de la República
los que han despenalizado el aborto
América qué le dijiste a las autoridades
el día de hoy en esta marcha que por fin
nos escuchen que se haga justicia por
todas las mujeres desaparecidas 11 de
cada 30 mujeres son asesinadas al día y
a la policía parece no importarle hay
más policías ahorita por nosotras que
solo salimos a manifestarnos que cuando
una mujer es atacada si no lleva signos
de violencia si no lleva golpes no le
creen tiene que ir prácticamente muerta
para querer pueden recibir su denuncia
Así es son distintas causas No nada más
el aborto las que en este día se
expresan Baja California Sur fue el
décimo estado apenas en junio pasado en
legislar para despenalizar la
interrupción del embarazo lo que exigen
es que haya armonía en la legislación de
todo el país y que se respeten los
derechos